The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: In the
example we looked at, we had a
list of ints.
That's actually quite easy
to do in constant time.
If you think about it, an int is
always going to occupy the
same amount of space, roughly
speaking, either 32 or 64
bits, depending upon
how big an int the
language wants to support.
So let's just, for the sake
of argument, assume an int
occupies four units of memory.
And I don't care
what a unit is.
Is a unit 8 bits, 16 bits?
It doesn't matter.
4 units.
How would we get to the i-th
element of the list?
What is the location in
memory of L-th of i?
Well, if we know the location
of the start of the list--
and certainly we can know that
because our identifier, say L
in this case, will point to
the start of the list--
then it's simply going to be
the start plus 4 times i.
My list looks like this.
I point to the start.
The first element is here.
So, that's start
plus 4 times 0.
Makes perfect sense.
The second element is here.
So, that's going to be
start plus 4 times 1.
Sure enough, this would be
location 4, relative to the
start of the list, et cetera.
This is a very conventional
way to implement lists.
But what does its correctness
depend upon?
It depends upon the fact that
each element of the list is of
the same size.
In this case, it's 4.
But I don't care if it's 4.
If it's 2, it's 2 times i.
If it's 58, it's 58 times i.
It doesn't matter.
But what matters is that each
element is the same size.
So this trick would work for
accessing elements of lists of
floats, lists of ints, anything
that's of fixed size.
But that's not the way
lists are in Python.
In Python, I can have a list
that contains ints, and
floats, and strings, and
other lists, and
dicts, almost anything.
So, in Python, it's not this
nice picture where the lists
are all homogeneous.
In many languages they
are, by the way.
And those languages would
implement it exactly as I've
outlined it on the board here.
But what about languages where
they're not, like Python?
One possibility--
and this is probably the oldest
way that people used to
implement lists--
is the notion of
a linked list.
These were used way back
in the 1960s, when
Lisp was first invented.
And, effectively, there,
what you do is a list.
Every element of the list is a
pointer to the next element.
And then the value.
So what it looks like in memory
is we have the list.
And this points to the next
element, which maybe has a
much bigger value field.
But that's OK.
This points to the
next element.
Let's say this one, maybe,
is a tiny value field.
And then at the end of the
list, I might write none,
saying there is no
next element.
Or nil, in Lisp speak.
But what's the cost here of
accessing the nth element of
the list, of the i-th
element of the list?
Somebody?
How many steps does it take
to find element i?
AUDIENCE: i.
AUDIENCE: i?
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
i steps, exactly.
So for a linked list, finding
the i-th element is order i.
That's not very good.
That won't help me with
binary search.
Because if this were the case
for finding an element of a
list in Python, binary search
would not be log length of the
list, but it would be order
length of the list.
Because the worst case is I'd
have to visit every element of
the list, say, to discover
something isn't in it.
So, this is not what
you want to do.
Instead, Python uses
something like the
picture in your handout.
And the key idea here is
one of indirection.
So in Python, what a list looks
like is it is a list, a
section of memory, a list of
objects each of the same size.
Because now what each
object is a pointer.
So we've now separated in
space the values of the
members of the list and the
pointers to, if you
will, the next one.
So now, it can be very simple.
This first element
could be big.
Second element could be small.
We don't care.
Now I'm back to exactly the
model we looked at here.
If, say, a pointer to someplace
in memory is 4 units
long, then to find l-th of i, I
use that trick to find, say,
the i-th pointer.
And then it takes me only one
step to follow it to get to
the object.
So, I can now, in constant time,
access any object into a
list, even though the
objects in the list
are of varying size.
This is the way it's done
in all object-oriented
programming languages.
Does that makes sense
to everybody?
This concept of indirection is
one of the most powerful
programming techniques
we have.
It gets used a lot.
My dictionary defines
indirection as a lack of
straightforwardness and openness
and as a synonym uses
deceitfulness.
And it had this pejorative term
until about 1950 when
computer scientists discovered
it and decided it was a
wonderful thing.
There's something that's often
quoted at people who do
algorithms.
They say quote, "all problems
in computer science can be
solved by another level of
indirection." So, it's sort
of, whenever you're stuck,
you add another level of
indirection.
The caveat to this is the one
problem that can't be solved
by adding another level of
indirection is too many levels
of indirection, which
can be a problem.
As you look at certain kinds of
memory structures, the fact
that you've separated the
pointers from the value fields
can lead to them being in very
far apart in memory, which can
disturb behaviors of caches
and things like that.
So in some models of memory this
can lead to surprising
inefficiency.
But most of the time
it's really a great
implementation technique.
And I highly recommend it.
So that's how we do the trick.
Now we can convince ourselves
that binary search is indeed
order log n.
And as we saw Tuesday,
logarithmic
growth is very slow.
So it means we can use binary
search to search enormous
lists and get the answer
very quickly.
All right.
There's still one catch.
And what's the catch?
There's an assumption
to binary search.
Binary search works only when
what assumption is true?
AUDIENCE: It's sorted.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: The
list is sorted because it
depends on that piece
of knowledge.
So, that raises the question,
how did it get sorted?
Or the other question it raises,
if I ask you to search
for something, does it make
sense to follow the algorithm
of (1) sort L, (2) use
binary search?
Does that make sense?
Well, what does it depend upon,
whether this makes sense
from an efficiency
point of view?
We know that that's order log
length of L. We also know if
the list isn't sorted, we can
do it in order L. We can
always use linear search.
So, whether or not this makes
a good idea depends upon
whether we can do this
fast enough.
It has the question is order
question mark plus order log
len of L less than order L?
If it's not, it doesn't make
sense to sort it first in
sums, right?
So what's the answer
to this question?
Do we think we can sort
a list fast enough?
And what would fast
enough mean?
What would it have to be?
For this to be better than this,
we know that we have to
be able to sort a list
in sublinear time.
Can we do that?
Alas, the answer
is provably no.
No matter how clever we are,
there is no algorithm that
will sort a list in
sublinear time.
And if you think of it, that
makes a lot of sense.
Because, how can you get
a list in ascending or
descending order without looking
at every element in
the list at least once?
Logic says you just
can't do it.
If you're going to put something
in order, you're
going to have to look at it.
So we know that we have a lower
bound on sorting, which
is order L. And we know that
order L plus order log length
L is the same as order L, which
is not better than that.
So why do we care?
If this is true, why are we
interested in things like
binary search at all?
And the reason is we're often
interested in something called
amortized complexity.
I know that there are some
course 15 students in the
class who will know what
amortization means.
But maybe not everybody does.
The idea here is that if we can
sort the list once and end
up searching it many times, the
cost of the sort can be
allocated, a little bit of it,
to each of the searches.
And if we do enough searches,
then in fact it doesn't really
matter how long the
sort takes.
So if we were going to search
this list a million times,
maybe we don't care
about the one-time
overhead of sorting it.
And this kind of amortized
analysis is quite common and
is what we really end up doing
most of the time in practice.
So the real question we want
to ask is, if we plan on
performing k searches--
who knows how long it will
take to sort it--
what we'll take is order of
whatever sort of the list is,
plus k times log length of
L. Is that less than k
times len of L?
If I don't sort it, to do
k sort searches will
take this much time.
If I do sort it, it will
The answer to this question, of
course, depends upon what's
the complexity of that
and how big is k.
Does that make sense?
In practice, k is
often very big.
The number of times we access,
say, a student record is quite
large compared to the
number of times
students enroll in MIT.
So if at the start of each
semester we produce a sorted
list, it pays off to
do the searches.
In fact, we don't do
a sorted list.
We do something more complex.
But you understand the
concept I hope.
Now we have to say, how
well can we do that?
That's what I want to spend most
of the rest of today on
now is talking about how do we
do sorting because it is a
very common operation.
First of all, let's look at
a way we don't do sorting.
There was a famous computer
scientist who
opined on this topic.
We can look for him this way.
A well-known technique
is bubble sort.
Actually, stop.
We're going to need
sound for this.
Do we have sound in the booth?
Do we have somebody
in the booth?
Well, we either have
sound or we don't.
We'll find out shortly.
Other way.
Come on.
You should know.
Oh there.
Thank you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Now, it's hard to get
a job as President.
And you're going through
the rigors now.
It's also hard to get
a job at Google.
We have questions, and we ask
our candidates questions.
And this one is from
Larry Schwimmer.
[LAUGHTER]
-You guys think I'm kidding?
It's right here.
What is the most efficient
way to sort a
million 32-bit integers?
[LAUGHTER]
-Well, uh.
-I'm Sorry, maybe
that's not a--
-I think the bubble sort would
be the wrong way to go.
[LAUGHTER]
-Come on, who told him this?
I didn't see computer science
in your background.
-We've got our spies in there.
-OK, let's ask a different
interval--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: All
right, so as he sometimes is,
the President was correct.
Bubble sort, though often
discussed, is almost always
the wrong answer.
So we're not going to talk
about bubble sort.
I, by the way, know Larry
Schwimmer and can believe he
did ask that question.
But yes, I'm surprised.
Someone had obviously warned
the President, actually the
then future president I think.
Let's look at a different one
that's often used, and that's
called selection sort.
This is about as simple
as it gets.
The basic idea of
selection sort--
and it's not a very good way
to sort, but it is a useful
kind of thing to look
at because it
introduces some ideas.
Like many algorithms, it depends
upon establishing and
maintaining an invariant.
An invariant is something
that's invariantly true.
The invariant we're going to
maintain here is we're going
to have a pointer
into the list.
And that pointer is going to
divide the list into a prefix
and a suffix.
And the invariant that we're
going to maintain is that the
prefix is always sorted.
We'll start where the
prefix is empty.
It contains none of the list.
And then each step through the
algorithm, we'll decrease the
size of the suffix by one
element and increase the size
of the prefix by one
element while
maintaining the invariant.
And we'll be done when the size
of the suffix is 0, and
therefore the prefix contains
all the elements.
And because we've been
maintaining this invariant, we
know that we have now
sorted the list.
So, you can think about it.
For example, if I have a list
that looks like 4, 2, 3, I'll
start pointing here.
And the prefix, which contains
nothing, obeys the invariant.
I'll then go through the list
and find the smallest element
in the list and swap it with
the first element.
My next step, the list will
look like 2, 4, 3.
I'll now point here.
My invariant is true.
The prefix contains only
one element, so it is
in ascending order.
And I've increased
its size by 1.
I don't have to look at this
element again because I know
by construction that's
the smallest.
Now I move here, and I look for
the smallest element in
the suffix, which will be 3.
I swapped 3 and 4.
And then I'm going to be done.
Does that make sense?
It's very straightforward.
It's, in some sense, the most
obvious way to sort a list.
And if you look at the code,
that's exactly what it does.
I've stated the invariant
here.
And I just go through
and I sort it.
So we can run it.
Let's do that.
I'm going to sort the list 3,
4, 5, et cetera, 35, 45.
I'm going to call
selection sort.
And I don't think this is in
your handout, but just to make
it obvious what's going on, each
iteration of the loop I'm
going to print the partially
sorted list so we can see
what's happening.
The first step, it finds 4 and
puts that in the beginning.
It actually finds 0, puts it in
the beginning, et cetera.
All right?
So, people see what's
going on here?
It's essentially doing
exactly what I did on
the board over there.
And when we're done, we have
the list completely sorted.
What's the complexity of this?
What's the complexity
of selection sort?
There are two things going on.
I'm doing a bunch
of comparisons.
And I'm doing a bunch
of swaps.
Since I do, at most, the same
number of comparisons as I do
swap or swaps as I
do comparisons--
I never swap without doing
a comparison--
we can calculate complexity by
looking at the number of
comparisons I'm doing.
You can see that in
the code as well.
So how many comparisons might
I have to do here?
The key thing to notice is each
time I look at it, each
iteration, I'm looking at
every element in what?
In the list?
No, every element
in the suffix.
The first time through,
I'm going to look at--
let's just say n equals the
length of the list.
So the first time through, I'm
going to look at n elements.
Then I'm going to look
at n minus 1.
at n minus 2.
Until I'm done, right?
So that's how many operations
I'm doing.
And what is the order of n plus
n minus 1 plus n minus 2?
Exactly.
Order n.
So, selection sort is order n.
Is that right?
Somebody said order n.
Do you believe it's n?
Is this really n?
It's not n.
What is it?
Somebody raise your hand, so
I can throw the candy out.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
It's not n factorial.
AUDIENCE: n-squared?
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: You said
that with a question mark
at the end of your voice.
AUDIENCE: No, it's like the sum
of the numbers is, like, n
times n minus 1 over 2 or
something like that.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: It's
really exactly right.
It's a little smaller
than n-squared,
but it's order n-squared.
I'm doing a lot of
these additions.
So I can't ignore all of
these extra terms and
say they don't matter.
It's almost as bad as comparing
every element to
every other element.
So, selection sort is
order n-squared.
And you can do it by
understanding that sum or you
can look at the code here.
And that sort of will
also tip you off.
Ok. so now, can we do better?
There was a while where people
were pretty unsure whether you
could do better.
But we can.
If we think about it now, it was
a method invented by John
von Neumann, a very
famous guy.
And he, back in the '40s
amazingly enough, viewed this
as a kind of divide and
conquer algorithm.
And we've looked at divide
and conquer before.
What is the general form
of divide and conquer?
A phrase you've heard me use
many times, popularized, by
the way, I think, by Machiavelli
in The Prince, in
a not very nice context.
So, what we do-- and they're
all of a kind, the same--
we start with 1.
Let me get over here and get
a full board for this.
First, we have to choose
a threshold size.
Let's call it n0.
And that will be, essentially,
the smallest problem.
So, we can keep dividing, making
our problem smaller--
this is what we saw with binary
search, for example--
until it's small enough that we
say, oh the heck with it.
We'll stop dividing it.
Now we'll just solve
it directly.
So, that's how small we need to
do it, the smallest thing
we'll divide things into.
The next thing we have to ask
ourselves is, how many
instances at each division?
We have a big problem.
We divide it into smaller
problems.
How many are we going
to divide it into?
We divide it into smaller
problems until we reach the
threshold where we can
solve it directly.
And then the third and most
important part is we need some
algorithm to combine
the sub-solutions.
It's no good solving the small
problem if we don't have some
way to combine them to solve
the larger problem.
We saw that before, and now
we're going to see it again.
And we're going to see it, in
particular, in the context of
merge sort.
If I use this board, can people
see it or is the screen
going to occlude it?
Is there anyone who cannot see
this board if I write on it?
All right then, I will
write on it.
Let's first look at
this problem.
What von Neumann observed
in 1945 is
given two sorted lists--
and amazingly enough, this is
still the most popular sorting
algorithm or one of the two most
popular I should say--
you can merge them quickly.
Let's look at an example.
I'll take the lists 1, 5,
12, 18, 19, and 20.
That's list one.
And I'll try and merge it with
the list 2, 3, 4, and 17.
The way you do the merge is
you start by comparing the
first element to the
first element.
And then you choose and
say all right, 1 is
smaller than 2.
So that will be the first
element of the merge list.
I'm now done with 1,
and I never have
to look at it again.
The next thing I do is I compare
5 and 2, the head of
the two remaining lists.
And I say, well, 2 is
smaller than 5.
I never have to look
at 2 again.
And then compare 5 and 3.
I say 3 is smaller.
I never have to look
at 3 again.
I then compare 4 and 5.
4 is smaller.
I then compare 5 and 17.
5 is smaller.
Et cetera.
Now, how many comparisons am
I going to do this time?
Well, let's first ask the
question, how many elements am
I going to copy from one of
these lists to this list?
Copy each element once, right?
So, the number of copies is
order len of the list.
That's pretty good.
That's linear.
That's sort of at
the lower bound.
But how many comparisons?
That's a little trickier
to think about.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: At most, the length
of the longer list.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: At most,
the length of the longer
list, which would also
be, we could claim to
be, order len of--
I sort of cheated using L
when we have two lists.
But just think of it
as the longer list.
So, you'd think that
many comparisons.
You think we can do this whole
thing in linear time?
And the answer is yes.
That's our merge.
That's a good thing.
Now, that takes care
of this step.
But now we have to ask,
how many times are we
going to do a merge?
Because remember, this
worked because
these lists were sorted.
And so I only had to compare
the front of each list.
When I think about how I'm going
to do the binary or the
merge sort, what I'm going to do
is take the original list,
break it up, break it up, break
it up, break it up,
until I have a list
of length 1.
Well, those are all sorted,
trivially sorted.
And then I'll have, at
the end, a bunch of
lists of length 1.
I'll merge pairs of those.
Now I'll have sorted
lists of length 2.
Then I'll merge those, getting
sorted lists of length 4.
Until at the end, I'll be
merging two lists, each half
the length of the
original list.
Right.
Does that make sense
to everybody?
Now I have to ask the question,
how many times am I
going to call merge?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Base 2 log of
one of the lists.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: Yes, I'm
going to call merge log
length of the list times.
So, if each merge is order n
where n is length of the list,
and I call merge log n times,
what's the total complexity of
the merge sort?
AUDIENCE: nlog(n).
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
nlog(n).
Thank you.
Let's see, I have to choose
a heavy candy
because they carry better.
Not well enough though.
All right, you can
relay it back.
Now let's look at an
implementation.
Here's the implementation
of sort.
And I don't think you need
to look at it in detail.
It's doing exactly what
I did on the board.
Actually, you do need to
look at in detail,
but not in real time.
And then sort.
Now, there's a little
complication here because I
wanted to show another
feature to you.
For the moment, we'll ignore the
complication, which is--
it's, in principle, working,
but it's not very bright.
I'll use the mouse.
What we see here is, whenever
you do a sort, you're sorting
by some ordering metric.
It could be less than.
It could be greater than.
It could be anything you want.
If you're sorting people, you
could sort them by weight or
you could sort them by height.
You could sort them by,
God forbid, GPA,
whatever you want.
So, I've written sort to take
as an argument the ordering.
I've used this funny thing
called lambda, which you don't
actually have to be
responsible for.
You're never going to, probably,
need to use it in
this course.
But it's a way to dynamically
build a function on the fly.
The function I've built is I've
said the default value of
LT is x less than y.
Lambda x, lambda xy says
x and y are the
parameters to a function.
And the body of the function is
simply return the value x
less than y.
All right?
Nothing very exciting there.
What is exciting is having a
function as an argument.
And that is something that
you'll be doing in future
problem sets.
Because it's one of the very
powerful and most useful
features in Python, is using
functional arguments.
Right.
Having got past that, what we
see is we first say if the
length of L is less than 2--
that's my threshold--
then I'm just going to return
L, actually a copy of L.
Otherwise, I'm going to find
roughly the middle of L.
Then I'm going to call sort
recursively with the part to
the left of the middle and the
part to the right of the
middle, and then merge them.
So I'm going to go all the way
down until I get to list of
length 1, and then bubble
all the way back up,
merging as I go.
So, we can see that the depth
of the recursion will be
log(n), as observed before.
This is exactly what we
looked at when we
looked at binary search.
How many times can you divide
something in half --
log(n) times?
And each recursion we're
going to call merge.
So, this is consistent with the
notion that the complexity
of the overall algorithm
is nlog(n).
Let's run it.
And I'm going to print as we
go what's getting merged.
Get rid of this one.
This was our selection sort.
We already looked at that.
Yeah.
So what we'll see here is the
first example, I was just
sorting a list of integers.
Maybe we'll look at that
all by itself.
I didn't pass it in the second
argument, so it used the
default less than.
It was first merge 4 and 5.
Then it had to merge 35
with 4 and 5, then 29
with 17, 58 and 0.
And then the longer list, 1729
with 058, 04535 with 0172958.
And then we were done.
So, indeed it did a logarithmic
number of merges.
The next piece of code, I'm
taking advantage of the fact
that this function can sort
lists of different kinds.
And I'm calling it now with
the list of floats.
And I am passing in the
second argument,
which is going to be--
well, let's for fun, I wonder
what happens if I make this
greater than.
Let's see what we get.
Now you note, it's sorted
it in the other order.
Because I passed in the ordering
that said I want to
use a different comparison then
less than, I want to use
greater than.
So the same code did the
sort the other way.
I can do more interesting
things.
So, here I'm assuming I
have a list of names.
And I've written two ordering
functions myself, one that
first compares the last names
and then the first names.
And a different one that
compares the first names and
then the last names.
And we can look at those.
Just to avoid cluttering
up the screen, let
me get rid of this.
What we can see is we got--
we did the same way of dividing
things initially, but
now we got different
orderings.
So, if we look at the first
ordering I used, we start with
Giselle Brady and then Tom
Brady and then Chancellor
Grimson, et cetera.
And if we do the second
ordering, we see, among other
things, you have me between
Giselle and Tom.
Not a bad outcome from
my perspective.
But again, a lot
of flexibility.
By using this functional
argument, I can define
whatever functions I want, and
using the same sort, get lots
of different code.
And you will discover that in
fact the built in sort of
Python has this kind
of flexibility.
You will also find, as you
write your own programs,
increasingly you'll want to use
functions as arguments.
Because it allows you to write
a lot less code to accomplish
the same tasks.